um thank you for joining us we will show
you some cool things that you can do
with spreadsheets and nodejs
you might know me from my talks about
the aid of JavaScript compilers but I
switch teams I work in the Google cloud
org now so I want to talk about cloud
stuff so this will be very different
from any other talks you might have seen
from me will give you sort of a basic
introduction to some of the Google cloud
platform products specifically server
less functions and we'll tie it all
together using spreadsheets for
prototyping conveniently sheets of
spreadsheets sheets is also part of
Google cloud so all the api's work
together really nicely
my name is Francisca Hinkleman I'm at
Google based in New York City and I'm a
member of the nodejs technical steering
committee and I'm co-presenting but Leah
hi I'm Leah Cole
I am beast out of Sunnyvale California
and I typically use node to write
samples for data analytics and ml
products and cloud and I am by no means
a node expert in fact Fonzie's my go-to
node expert especially when I want
advice on best policies for our samples
and I'm also a super-duper G suite
enthusiast I definitely use G suite
before Google but once I started using
it everyday for my work I found that I
started using it outside of work too to
like plan vacations and stuff all right
so let's get started with work less and
do more sheets for note developers why
are we talking to you about spreadsheets
well the great thing about spreadsheets
is that they allow you to collaborate
with anybody not just with developers
spreadsheets they have this universal
language you might say that pretty much
anybody can pick up so anybody that you
want to work with regardless of their
background they can edit the data they
can read the data they can filter data
sorted play around with it and draw
their own conclusions which can
sometimes be really useful I'm sorry my
part
because crying alright so sheets are
good if you want to collaborate with
non-engineers and not only can pretty
much anybody work with the sheets sheets
make it really easy to visualize data
and so you can analyze your data by
looking at the visuals you created
obviously you can create all kinds of
visuals pad pie charts bar bar charts
line graphs whatever and yes as
engineers we could write code we could
use d3.js and generate really pretty
graphs but it usually takes a lot longer
than just using a sheet to visualize
some data and when I need to iterate
quickly then sheets allow me to focus on
the trends and correlations instead of
the code so lots of advantages to sheets
and because of all the sheets are really
useful when you want to prototype
something with data and metrics so
probably not for a full-fledged serious
production product but if you're just
prototyping and you want to iterate
quickly sheets give you a lot of
advantages I don't know about you though
but I do not enjoy entering and
manipulating data in spreadsheets but
it's because it's not something that I
do all the time I do think though that
sheets are an awesome tool for the
output and especially for beautiful
visualizations like this one and so
that's why we're going to use that today
but because the manual parts aren't fun
we're going to eliminate them and
instead automate them and because we're
at node and J is interactive and we love
node we're going to use that I mean you
heard Franzese a node core contributor
and on the technical steering committee
and she talks about how awesome note is
a lot and it's she it's a good influence
before I was working with her I
definitely gravitated towards Python in
Java because that was what I was more
comfortable with but especially now that
async/await makes things more readable
I definitely gravitate more towards node
for that automating alright so we're
gonna start by writing this node
application to work with sheets we're
going to install the Google API is
client
very from the NPM registry like so and
it's a full-fledged
API for talking to sheets that we're
going to use but before we dive in I do
want to give a quick shout out to the G
suite api's as a whole if you're not
sure we've been using this term G suite
a lot it's our family of productivity
tools so it's not just sheets which
we're focusing on today but it's also
dark slides gmail calendar among other
things and you can call all of those
api's for free which is awesome because
free stuff is great you don't have to
have an enterprise account and as Fonzie
said earlier G suite is part of Google
cloud which also encompasses Google
cloud platform so if you've ever played
around with Google cloud platform and
use those api's using the G suite api's
is pretty much the same it's the same
account same family they are generated
the same way you turn those api's on the
same way which is great and if you are
at this conference and maybe aren't a
node person or maybe you're new to node
if you're not we do have these client
libraries and other languages but
because we're at node and J is
interactive we are going to focus on
node today so let's take a look at hello
world and sheets this could just be a
script that's running locally on my
machine and we'll start by requiring
that package that we just got from the
NPM registry so we'll start by
initializing the sheets client and then
above that we see this string that has
our scopes and so that's the level of
access that we want to grant this script
we know that files live in Google Drive
with other file types like Docs and
slides but specifically we only want to
write to spreadsheets today I don't know
about you but I get really nervous when
any kind of application asks for
permissions that I think they shouldn't
have like wanting to get into my Drive
folders and see everything in my emails
in my location history in my mother's
maiden name like we don't want that best
practice is definitely to restrict to
only what we need so here we're going to
make our hello world call and we're
going to say which cell or cells we want
to put things into in sheets so in
cheese we use what's called a1 notation
and that's because a1 is that cell
that's in the top left corner of the
sheet and that is where we're going to
be writing our hello world today
and we're also using async/await because
we love that but if you did want to use
a previous version of node you could do
that with the script too and don't worry
about trying to memorize it we have all
this code on github and we'll show this
link again at the end all right so
here's what the code looks like when we
run super cool HelloWorld and a one just
like where we said it was going to be
and I'm not sure if you remember from
the last cell there was this variable
that was called spreadsheet ID and this
spreadsheet ideas in that red box at the
top that's the same ID that you'd find
in the browser with any spreadsheet
you'd have open so that's what tells us
to write to this Google sheet in
particular alright but let's be real
most the time you need to do more than
just write hello world to one single
cell and the best way to make multiple
modifications to one sheet is to batch
your requests together in this method
this batch update request is very common
across all of the G suite api's so why
should you group your requests there are
two main reasons the first is that every
call is going to have a little bit of
network latency so if you group them
together you can save yourself from that
and the second is that while the api's
are free there is a quota so if you
battery requests together they will
count as one towards your quota instead
of many so definitely want to optimize
for that so each of these like
mysterious tasks could be a different
kind of request like it could be writing
data like we did with hello world or it
could be adding a chart or formatting a
cell or deleting a sheet altogether
filtering your data if you name it like
if it's in the Google sheets UI you can
do it in the API which is pretty great
we say it's like a big hammer for all
kinds of things you can do or insert
your favorite tool I don't know so we
have this basic toolkit for working with
the sheets API and we're doing it in
node so let's talk about a real-world
problem I don't sit in the same office
as fronds they were across the country
from each other but one thing we do have
in common is our love of open source and
we also both really love the insights
tab and github it tells you so much
about your project and I know Franzi
there's a lot of looking at open issues
and PRS
we're looking at the nodejs node repo
the node core node runtime right now and
if you're to go there you could see all
the changes going in for node 14 and
Fonzie is really concerned with the
health of the node runtime overall and
is a very metrics oriented person but
the thing about the insights tab is it
really only tells you info about github
they're just numbers like what is nine
hundred and one issues mean without
additional context do we know if that's
healthy or not for node and like it's
because a lot of other factors affect
productivity like if a product team were
to come in and change a ton of
requirements that's gonna change your
velocity who's ever been there or if
your to have a ton of technical debt
that can slow you down but on the other
hand if you have really good test
coverage and continuous integration that
can make things good or what if like
people are hangry and that makes them
not as productive like you get it
frosting with a holistic picture of what
goes into making the node repo healthy
and what helps folks be more productive
so we're gonna focus on the question
that I mentioned there that's hard to
define we're gonna be a little bit silly
and we want an experiment to find out if
food satisfaction yields better github
metrics so this is a hard problem not
just from a technical perspective but
because it's a real-world problem - we
have our contributors at their machines
we have github we have food and we want
to write a prototype to automate
gathering information about all of those
and that's why we're gonna use sheets
for the prototyping to manipulate the
data and of course we're going to do it
in node so that we can use node to
monitor the node repo so let's start by
breaking down that problem so my
intuition is that when we're well fed we
write better code but we care about
metrics so let's start with the data
node core is a very active repo and we
would like to know how many open Pro
requests do we have how many issues and
how many PRS are we merging and how many
issues are we are we closing
luckily the github API provides all this
data for us and using our ticket
the github the client for JavaScript
it's very easy to get this data it's
just a few straight-up API calls and we
know how many open issues we have
instead of looking at the website so I'm
collecting this data by doing a few
calls to ticket have API and then just
like in the hello world example that
Leah showed us I use a Sheetz API call
to write this data into a spreadsheet
now obviously when I'm getting the data
from github I could just copy it and
then paste it into a spreadsheet that
would work instead of talking to the API
but it's manual work I have to do this
every time I want to update the data and
it's error-prone so I'd rather add
another two lines to my script that
already pulls the data and then push it
writer to the spreadsheet by using the
sheets API alright so now for the food
part um we left surveys so we just did a
survey where we figured out how happy
the node contributors in our office are
with their food on a given day clearly
this is very scientific we're using the
the Google Form for Google survey if
you've used it before the results are
already automatically stored in a
spreadsheet if you use anything else to
gather gather your data just do another
sheets API call to writer to the
spreadsheet just like we did with the
github data alright so now we have both
the data for food and for github and we
want to know are there any correlations
what's a good way to find correlations
well if we can visualize the data that
would help us so here's the chart we'll
look at the results in detail later for
now we're interested in how did we
generate this chart of course you can
click in the UI to generate a chart but
we don't want to use the browser we
don't want to open sheets we want to
script all of this so we don't make any
mistakes that we don't do any manual
labor and yes there is you guys did an
API call to generate a chart so what
does the code look like we create an add
chart request and we have to define the
chart and its specifications so here we
are defining
chart type we're picking a line shot and
then we have to specify the domain so
the x-axis of your chart in our case
that's the different dates that we're
interested in and then we also have to
enter this series two different data
points we have from github and from the
food survey and once we've defined the
chart then we call this badge update
method that can do pretty much anything
for us and we send the add chart request
all right so we started with these data
sources we have some data from the
github API we have some data from a form
and then we do a write API call to the
sheets API to put this data into the
sheet and we do another API call to
generate a chart for us and if we do
this we never have to open the sheet in
a browser
all our scripts run locally so we can
decide what node version we want how to
run it and all that it's just a little
script that we run the talks to the
sheet API but Lia is going to take this
one step further now thanks for him all
right
so at this point we're gathering data
we're getting insights but it is only
running locally on one machine for Anzhi
knives and across the country from each
other this is not going to be super
great for collaborating if it is only on
one machine locally so we should
probably be hosting it as a service
ideally it would be like a full-fledged
application but we need a client and a
server and I mean if we really want to
be abiding by good cloud principles
there would be high availability fault
tolerance which would mean multiple
servers and load balancing and a cache
and that's a lot of pieces we said this
was a prototype
let's not we want to focus on our code
not our infrastructure so instead we
decided to go with a server list
solution which in Google cloud platform
is called Google cloud functions so you
just upload those narrow focus bits of
codes to GCP and the cloud provider
figures out where to put it now to scale
it on your behalf you don't have to know
anything about the machines that it's
running on and you only pay for when
it's executing you don't have to manage
your servers security is taken care of
you can use the languages tools and
frameworks you're familiar with
so if it snowed you're doing it and
Express python is flask there's also go
in Java runtimes when they're triggered
by various events so there are two types
of events in cloud functions and we have
there's like background functions that
are triggered by events like if you
upload something to a cloud storage
bucket or send a pub/sub message or it
can be triggered by an HTTP function
which is what we're going to focus on
today so those are great for processing
data are calling external services I
know in the real world folks use them to
talk to things like stripe and Twilio so
let's take a look at the hello world for
functions for HTTP functions when I say
function do I mean a function yeah it's
only two lines of code and we have a
fully functioning back-end which is
super cool
if you've used Express before those
requests and response objects should
look pretty familiar let's where they're
from and so with all of this no
additional configuration you end up with
an HTTP endpoint at a fully qualified
domain with dynamically generated SSL
TLS certificates and that's what it
would look like in the browser okay so
now that we're familiar with cloud
functions we're gonna wrap up the code
we have in our local script and deploy
it there so we have our server list
back-end it'll read that data from the
sources and produce the chart while
running in the data center so franzine I
can actually be useful to each other
sitting in our offices all right so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna take the
code we already have and wrap it up in
an exported function called github chart
to call our main logic and then when the
processing is done we'll send that 200
success just like we did in the hello
world and we'll send also the ID of the
spreadsheet that we've been working with
okay so how do we actually do this
deployment we did it using the G cloud
CLI tool which is what you can use to
manage all of your GCP tasks and for
cloud functions you just pass the name
of the function that you're going to use
and then also we specified that it's an
HTTP trigger and it uploads your code
and it picks up the package JSON which
is great but not the modules because
that would be a ton of stuff and so this
is great for if your internet
actions not SuperDuper and those
dependencies are then downloaded in the
cloud and used by it
you could also edit the package.json and
the function if you wanted to in this UI
the cloud console which is nice for
quick fixes I love a command-line but I
do also love a useful UI especially for
a quick fix all right so at this point
our codes in the cloud which is sweet
but it still needs to be triggered
manually if you're doing something where
you want to be pulling in data regularly
you don't want it to be triggered
manually that stinks that means you have
to remember to do it so instead of
needing a human we chose to use cloud
scheduler to run our code it's basically
a big fancy cron in the cloud you set up
the cron job in the cloud console that's
the same UI that you can use for cloud
functions and you use the same syntax as
if you're using normal cron our job runs
every morning at 9:00 and we specify the
HTTP URL to trigger that cloud function
and so at this point we have the data
collection job in the backend and Franz
E's going to talk you through adding a
client alright so we have two code in
the cloud but we have to remember that
we add URL for the HTTP endpoint and
would be just a little more convenient
if we had a UI client for it
so we did that we added a client that
shows you the chart and if you click on
share analysis the data is updated once
more and then the new chart is sent out
to all your teammates so we have two
data updating at 9:00 a.m. every morning
anyways but we don't want to spam
everybody daily so we're only sending
out emails if somebody consciously
clicks touche analysis button and a
front-end that's that's why we have to
front it and since we are sending out
emails we're using the Gmail API for
this task just like in the service no
js' code we have client libraries for
front-end JavaScript as well and again
those make it much easier to talk to the
Google REST API than if you were to
directly script against a rest interface
so we're doing Gmail that users that
messages that send and we pass in as a
resource to raw email which can be HTML
or plain
texts so now we have the front end order
crunch up the triggers our cloud
function and then the cloud function
pulls in the new data and the cloud
function also generates a new chart and
then the Gmail API and the front end
sends out the new chart to the team
members all right pretty easy so far
right start the whole story though
what's the big thing that we left out we
left out off we never mentioned that and
we are we're sending emails pretending
to be somebody and we're reading and
writing spreadsheets and clearly I don't
want people to be able to read my
spreadsheets just because they figured
out how to use two sheets API that's not
a good security model so let's look at
how authorization works in our app in
the front end we actually have a little
authorize or login button and when
people click that then the Google
sign-in flow is triggered and Google
sign-in is a secure syndication system
that allows your users to log in with
their Google Account that they already
have and then they can authorize your
apps in this case to send emails they
can authorize your app to use Google
services on behalf of these end users
and all of this is happening in a secure
manner
all right so Google uses the OAuth 2
protocol and the application needs user
consent before it can access the data
just like you saw the end user has to
consent to send out emails on their
behalf and the key point of oath too is
that the application does not have to
use as credentials the users locked in
but they didn't login to your app they
locked into the Google auth service and
then they only gave consent so that's a
big plus because you don't have to worry
about storing these credentials security
securely because you don't get them
always to relies on consent not on
credentials let's look at how this
protocol works in detail so more
specifically the authorization flow is
called three-legged OAuth it's three-leg
because there are three entities
so there's your application there the
Google servers and then there are the
end users so when your application wants
to make a request to the Google server
then the user is prompted to login and
to consent and if they do so
successfully then your application
receives a token and after validating
the token the application can use this
token to make API calls to the Google
applique
luckily the client libraries handle this
somewhat complicated workflow for you
one thing that Lea showed us earlier was
that you have to specify the scope so
just like in the back end and the front
end we have to specify the scope before
initializing the Google client
so here the scope is for Gmail that sent
and that's why the sign-in flow said do
you consent to this application sending
emails on your behalf now if the user
agrees to that and then your app gets a
token back and now you take this valid
token and you try to read the user
spreadsheets even though it's a valid
token it's not valid for the spreadsheet
scopes you get a 4:3 so only what the
user consented to and that's specified
by the scope that you pass in is makes
the token valid for all right so in the
front end we have an end user clicking
the login button we use three like OS
with
our consent how do we handle us in the
backend where we just have a cloud
function talking to the sheets API but
no end users it's it's a server less
cloud function no front and no nothing
well we since end users are not directly
involved we use server-to-server
authentication and in this case the
spreadsheet belongs to the application
rather than to an end user heads-up
though whenever you work on a production
app not just a little prototype like we
did you always want to use three-legged
OS for anything involving G suite so
when you work with with Docs or sheets
or slides or the file drive you always
want to use three-legged OAuth and use
end-user consent the reason is if this
is a production app and you have
millions of users and all of a sudden
this application owns millions of
documents and spreadsheets and that's
way over the quota so your default is
whenever you use Docs or access like
that use three-legged OAuth in our
little prototype though we don't worry
about that we just have one team looking
at this it's not a million files it's
one spreadsheet so we can just do server
to server earth this is also referred to
as two letters can anybody guess why Wow
there's only two entities involved
obviously there's no end user
there's your application and there's two
Google service and four server-to-server
authentication you can make your
authorized API calls using a JSON web
token a JIT instead of an access token
and again if you use the client
libraries they handle all of this for
use you don't have to worry about
creating or signing a JIT so comparing
three-leg and to like OS ours three leg
is on behalf of end users it requires
users consent and it's the best practice
when you work with a G suite API to
elect is for server-to-server
authentication it's on behalf of the
application and the resources to
documents they have to belong to the
application
Thank You Francie for that deep dive
into off so like Fonzie said this is
handled for you by the client libraries
which is awesome and if you wanted to
take a look at our quick starts in our
documentation they will walk you through
the authentication path in just a few
steps and just remember we want to use
OAuth because we want tokens not
passwords we don't want those stored in
plain text ever but let's get back to
the whole point of building this app we
want to know if food satisfaction
affects github repo health and
productivity so we made a lot of charts
showing food satisfaction against github
metrics on the left side we have open
issues in PRS and on the right side we
have the happiness scale and the
original survey ran from 1 to 5 where 5
was the most happy so let's actually
look at a smaller easier to read chart
so this is closed in issues and merged
PRS against food happiness food
happiness is the red thick line that
goes across with the hump in the middle
and if you blue is the closest use green
as the merged PRS if you're not sure
which is which the most important thing
to note is that they all have that hump
around the same time which makes us
think that food satisfaction does affect
github metrics which is cool but know
that you could also use these things for
other internal systems or application
monitoring that's maybe not as silly as
this but we do want to show you that we
have the proof that good food yields
good code we do want to add one last
thing onto our system though another
workflow we see a lot is that folks have
to create reports of data regularly
either for their managers or for a
broader team meeting and they often have
to do it at a repeated time interval
like weekly monthly quarterly or sales
folks have to make customized reports
for their clients if you don't have to
do it someone you work with somewhere
probably does so we're gonna pretend
that we want to approve our good friend
good food trend continues over time and
we're going to share this with folks all
across the company in our report and
we're going to script it because doing
it manually it sounds awful I don't know
if you've ever had to update one of
these reports but doing it manually like
it works you can start by copying an old
and like moving in the new data but I
know I'm prone to copypasta errors paste
errors and it's very tedious so instead
we're gonna create a template with
placeholders for the things that we know
we're going to replace like the current
date and we're going to completely
automate it so we'll have first the
Google Drive API create a copy of this
template every time we need it and we'll
use the slides API to tie it all
together in this spreadsheet so we'll
initialize that client to make
modifications and this should look a lot
like the other Google G suite api's
we've been using and if you remember in
that template I showed a couple slides
ago where we had the placeholder for the
date in curly brackets that's what we're
highlighting here that's what we want to
replace and we want to use a replace
text call to replace it with today's
date and if you weren't sure this is
going to be a batch update we could also
be making other replacements at the same
time like if we wanted to submit the
number of pull requests that were close
or issues at the same time we could do
that on this call that is gross the good
news is we only have a few more slides
hello
just went on it did
okay
it's okay
okay
sweet alright so now we're gonna figure
out how to add our charts so it's nice
about the api's is they're just as
tightly coupled as the products
themselves are so slides has an API
called I can insert insert a Google
sheets chart just by its chart ID so you
can generate these reports with up to
date data no human intervention either
save yourself or your co-workers tons of
time you could become that person who
has to generate the reports new best
friends by teaching them this so just a
quick review we designed a basic
reporting system using node that calls
Google cloud function using those two
suite api's and it fetches data from
external sources and shares that back to
the user either through the Gmail or
through an automated report in slides
and at its core we're using sheets for
the data collection and the manipulation
so we wanted to know if the food
effective github productivity maybe you
wanted to know that too or maybe you
want to take the solution to make it fit
your needs if so this is where the code
lives in github and we would love to
inspire you to either try this or try
something similar like be creative take
a non-technical problem and try to solve
it with the tools you use every day or a
tool that you want to try out so you can
get better at it
we also want to do a quick shout-out to
our friend and colleague a new service
diva who helped write a lot of this code
to make this awesome thank you the
conference for having us and for you for
coming will answer your questions
probably in the hallway or at the Google
booth because I think we're running low
on time so thank you
[Applause]